[Music starts]
[Nash Rochman, PhD] There's a very
old saying in physics that "it's great
to be able to explain but it's better to predict".
But it's also true that it's impossible to predict
without an understanding, without an explanation.
If we're ever going to have a deeper
understanding of of any biological system,
for example, a relationship between a novel
virus and a human host, we're going to need
to have a deeper understanding of host-pathogen
relationships with the information we have today.
So I study host-pathogen interactions
and these could be human hosts and
viral pathogens like SARS-Cov2.
Host-pathogen relationships involve cancer
in the host, or viruses in the host,
or bacterial systems in the host.
They could be animal hosts
and bacterial pathogens. They
could even be bacterial hosts and viral pathogens.
And I want to find unifying forces that shape
the interactions between hosts and pathogens,
to predict how the biology of the host can shape
the evolution of the pathogen, and vice versa.
And this is important obviously for just
understanding basic problems in biology.
But also, I think this is an
interesting area because it
provides immediate practical application as well.
Obviously, if you can find some forces
that are shaping viral evolution,
you might be able to use that information
to help design better vaccines.
If you find forces that are
shaping bacterial evolution,
in response to a virus, you might be able to
find ways to better invent new antibiotics.
So, with more and more data,
you can start predicting when
the next pandemic will be or
what the next pandemic will be.
If you can predict, before it happens, you
could even prevent the first human infection
by mitigating the spread of that virus
within the intermediate host population.
And if you're really good, you
can make that time negative.
So you can mitigate it before it's
ever isolated within a human host.
I want to help build a deeper understanding of
well-conserved biological features - so that you
can make longer timescale predictions, so you
can better respond to biological rare events.
[Music]
[Music fades to silence]